des manifestants aux idéologies
extrémistes violentes prêtes à mourir
pour leurs causes et armés jusqu'aux
dents au blocage de coude en Alberta
voilà qui a convaincu le ministre de la
Sécurité publique qu'il fallait invoquer
la Loi sur les mesures d'urgence
Marco Mendicino le 13 février provenait
de Brenda Lucky commissaire de la GRC
des agents d'infiltration de la police
fédérale avaient confirmé l'existence
d'une cage d'armes à feu de munitions et
de vestes par balles dans le village
frontalier ou était rassemblés des
manifestants depuis le 29 janvier
pourtant ce 13 février à la veille de
l'invocation de la Loi sur les mesures
d'urgence la grande patronne de la GRC
croyait qu'il existait d'autres recours
pour mettre fin aux occupations et aux
barricades affirmant que les policière
avait élaboré un plan et non
plus tard Dominique Leblanc ministre des
Affaires intergouvernementsales a
affirmé à la commission que pour geler
les comptes bancaires des manifestants
qui participaient à des activités
illégales à l'extérieur de leur province
de résidence il fallait accorder des
pouvoirs aux institutions financières
partout au pays pour que les mesures
économiques soient efficaces
il fallait avoir une application
nationale parce que si quelqu'un avait
une compte de banque par exemple par la
Caisse populaire
au Québec ou à la Banque Nationale ce
sera pas à l'abri des mesures
économiques nécessaires dans notre
jugement pour amener ces actes illégales
à une conclusion
les esprits se sont échauffés l'avocat
du convoi des camionneurs d'Ottawa a
demandé au commissaire Paul rouleau que
9 documents protégés soit des caviardés
le commissaire l'a expulsé de la salle
le commissaire a rejeté en partie la
demande de Brandon Miller avocat du
convoi des camionneurs d'Ottawa les
documents qui sont protégés par le
privilège parlementaire seront dévoilés
intégralement mais pas se protéger par
le secret du cabinet Brendan Miller a pu
retourner en salle d'audience après
avoir offert ses excuses au commissaire
ici Valérie Michael
Ottawa